it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share items that might help
make your day a little bit better all at
exclusive discounts this week we're
bringing back four of our favorites and
some of the most popular items to start
shopping now scan that QR code on your
screen right there on the top left or
visit cbsdeals.com joining us now is
Candy Carter Chief content officer at
the e-commerce company knocking candy
what up oh my God so I'm so excited
because first of all these are the
favorites and we bring them back okay so
that people can get them and a few of
these things sell out when we do it so
go to cbsdeals.com right now because the
prices are good you're going to be able
to get more than one thing okay so
pickleball are you playing yet I mean
it's the fastest growing sport I guess
in the country okay Dana plays I love it
so first time my husband and I are on
vacation last week we finally all of our
friends play we finally did it we had a
blast right gotta have some beers but we
rented let me move on we rented paddles
right but then I came back and I used a
rock me paddle night and day so check
this out if you're a beginner right the
key is you hit the sweet spot with this
paddle they extended the sweet pot
Across The Sweet Spot across the whole
paddle so if you're a beginner when you
hit it
anywhere you hit it it's going to go
straight it's really great but these are
paddles they use in tournaments right so
if you're a more advanced player you get
spin you get Precision it's really great
super light love it but like I'm 54
right so we're older so this is like
something I can do with my husband right
I got my little backswing going
two-handed it's got a longer handle so I
love these so much 179 normally right
yep 112 dollars today and it's great
almost 40 off so get in the sport right
because you want to start with a good
paddle so you don't have to get a cheap
one and then upgrade later okay I love
the Roxy paddle okay so this is she's
birdie it's a personal safety alarm so
here's the deal
if you are I worked at Oprah for years
right and we should always say don't go
to the second location well guess what
I'm not trying to go to the first
location okay so these are it's a
personal alarm so I'm gonna pull it it's
gonna be noisy here we go just
so what happens is you know you have
this but your attacker doesn't right
right so the idea is it's enough of a
distraction that hopefully you can get
away okay you know what I'm saying and
so I love these because I have a 14 year
old who walks home alone I give it to
her I was at a parking lot like a
parking garage at night and I looked up
I was like oh my God I'm by myself right
and so this gives you so much safety and
listen people can't use it against you
how much all right this is uh 19.99 it's
20 bucks but if you had a taser or mace
they could spray you with it these are
some of the most popular items the most
popular college kids everybody yourself
keeps you safe okay love love drops up
okay one of the biggest selling products
on Shark Tank right so look at this
picture I have this I have the drops up
in my car so you know how you like drop
stuff in the side look at that you never
like the first instinct is to go get it
so the guys who founded this he dropped
his phone he looked up he was on a
sidewalk he could have killed somebody
eighty percent of accidents happen
because people are distracted right the
entire LAPD uses these they're amazing
look at this just slide it over the seat
belt look at that stuff doesn't drop
down the one in my car is filthy because
I drop everything and you can wash it so
check this out okay 15.99 and you get
two wow one for the driver's side one
for the passenger pretty good deal Works
in most cars highly recommend get it to
all your young drivers everybody I love
these ridiculous okay listen everybody
loves this oh my God so I go on vacation
our friend we run into our friend
Clarence funny he literally takes his
shoe off look at this picture and shows
me he goes I got the socks no way ran
into randomly
I'm obsessed because of this thing on
the top they don't slide that's the
biggest problem yeah a little tiny the
ones I'm wearing I've washed like seven
eight times they're exactly the same
it's fantastic so I love them listen
9.99 to 44.99 you can buy the single you
can buy the five pack the three pack get
all of them okay I recommend okay really
quick you guys showed this picture me
yesterday with this notifications
straight out of my suitcase but we
washed at the hotel so check this out
I'm in the pool right I had to go to the
bathroom yeah can't pee in the pool so I
get out and I'm like oh be quiet I don't
want to dry off and then have to put my
cover up on right so I literally put
this on it took two seconds I'm like
patting myself dry to the bathroom ran
and ran back and I was like oh my God
that was amazing don't remind people how
much those cost uh let's see the simple
sarongs are 23 to 32 and they have them
for kids I love it I love it Candy
Carter yay lots of good stuff of course
we partner with all these companies to
get you these deals to buy anything you
saw today scan that QR code on your
screen or head over to cbsdeals.com to
start shopping right now we'll be right
back